okay so they don't know who what the
hell happened around well they said her
[ __ ] was throbbing yeah that's the first
thing they checked so she was in the
middle of an orgasm don't worry I'm a
lesbian doctor
[Music]
okay we need another uh JK mystery team
assembly let's go baby this one's gonna
be really hard to figure out because
there is no answer to what the hell
happened here but it's a really
interesting story there's always an
answer there's never a question oh we're
gonna hear it today New York okay this
kid
leaves his house
on a skateboard to go get food at 8 50
PM right yeah makes sense does it all
the time just casual day in uh Manhattan
keep in mind the sidewalks in New York
are [ __ ] up they are and how do they
skate
at a certain time of night there's so
much trash outside like on the [ __ ]
curb but you couldn't skate around that
no he went to get a chopped cheese or
something right or a Halal Guys yeah
Halal Guys it could be or a pizza so he
leaves his house 8 50 p.m on a
skateboard starts going by 9 13 p.m he's
checked into the hospital with no
explanation and half of his skull is
missing 23 minutes half of his skull
accident those [ __ ] sidewalk so
that's what he he really doesn't think
that he just fell he don't remember oh
he doesn't he doesn't remember and
there's no record there's even the
hospital doesn't even have a record of
how he got did someone chop off the half
of his head he thinks that it was a hit
and run and and that person who hit him
might have been someone important enough
to erase like that's way easier than
that so you know in those [ __ ] New
York buildings always got those goddamn
fire escapes yeah so someone was just
trying to sneak out and then he hit the
button where the [ __ ] ladder just
went down and just smashed him in the
head that only happens but why would
they so simple and the ladder goes back
up it's clean at some point someone
called it an ambulance for him so they
saw him on the street yeah but it's New
York everyone Minds their own business
so they go hey I'm walking yeah oh [ __ ]
father yeah
the realization when he sees the guy
with a skull missing he's like yeah that
sentence has never had a question mark
until now and it's a perfect scenario he
probably failed with oh and he's
perfectly pressed three nine on 911
numbers
the crazy thing is that whoever called
whoever called the ambulance reported it
as a drug overdose
hey there's a [ __ ] crackhead here
yeah that could be it yeah New Yorkers
are judgy though yeah so that's the only
thing is that there's on the paperwork
it's it's recorded as a drug overdose
but actually he had like such a bad
concussion and uh it was hemorrhaging to
the point where they had to cut his
skull off oh [ __ ] so it was blunt force
trauma or something to his head that's
what caused it is there any other
injuries to the rest of his body like
bending broken bones nothing well he was
sucked completely dry out of his dick
foreign
we did a whole report and he had no
sperm in that nut sack his balls empty
that's the first thing they check when
they see a guy check his dick he's like
concussion he's like don't worry I'm a
gay doctor
yeah I got this I know this
karyotypical gay
yeah so it's been two years since this
happened wow and uh this story is kind
of making you know Headway now because
there's still no answer to it no ring
cameras trying to figure it out no
cameras anywhere he's still alive he's
still alive yeah he can he has a piece
of his skull that he can hold in his
hand the size of his hand whoa what if
he'd really did just slip and then fall
on the back of his head yeah that's what
that's what he's being told but he's
just not convinced that that happened
yeah but also and then a bystander could
have been like yeah some junkies [ __ ]
knocked out here all right and then they
walk away like [ __ ] because because
when guys get like hardcore blunt force
trauma like that sometimes they tend to
forget what happened yeah that's true
today not that I think you're gonna know
this because I sit in that chair all the
time do they put like a plate there now
yeah okay no I don't know yeah exactly
I figured
I think they do put a metal plate yeah
yeah and
crazy a piece of his skull came out like
a [ __ ] three green onion pen well
it's like in you know like when you're
when your brain is swelling the only
thing they can do is make room for the
swelling yeah because they can't chop
your brain off right or let's say
lobotomize you so what what are people
thinking that it is well there's there's
people there are people that think that
he just fell and he just hit his head
someone ran a person said hey some
somebody's on an OD or something because
he was probably spazzing so they called
that and then the hospital came and then
someone just lost the record and then
the conspiracy side of it thinks that
you know an affluent person hit him
accidentally driving like a rich person
and then you know they got him in the
hospital and then they said hey I was
never here because if he got hit by a
car it would be he would have more than
just his like skull being broken you
know like he would probably have other
residual
like damage unless the car just like hit
a ramp and just got him in the head the
back of a scooter hit him or something
if it's a fast movie and a fast movie
that would happen oh yeah yeah yeah have
you guys diesel was behind the wheel
have you guys ever seen a knight of oh
yeah HBO it was like just we only had
one season and it's based off a true
story and it's this uh this guy he dates
a chick
and I believe
um they they go to his his house they
bang and I think when he wakes up or
something or maybe he left
um I'm telling the story The Way Joe
would tell it because I forgot what
happened yeah but when they arrived at
the chick's house she would stabbed the
[ __ ] up like 30 times and he was the
last person at her house and they still
don't know what happened how did they
bang was it doggy style
um good question I think so it was one
of the positions did she even get to
calm though because that's what I think
they checked the clitoris and it was
throbbing so I think so maybe yeah okay
so they don't know who what the hell
happened around well they said her [ __ ]
was throbbing yeah that's the first
thing they checked so she was in the
middle of an orgasm don't worry I'm a
lesbian doctor
from television you know one of those
famous ones from 90s must-see TV from an
infantile Television TV show so anyone
have any other theories besides those
two on what happened to this guy I've
seen an old man walk on [ __ ] Garfield
Avenue
in the the dumpster the trash truck was
backing up and then you know they have
all these Jagged parts and it just hits
them in the back of the head and then he
just falls to the ground why was this
dumbass walking there he's just being an
old Asian man I guess and then he was
just like just walking and then he hits
the ground he starts crying and [ __ ] oh
uh oh my God what did the dumpster guy
go oh [ __ ] I don't even think he knew
what oh yeah cause how would you know
you're gonna feel it I was with my dad
and you know like Asian dads always have
a [ __ ] stack of napkins like this
from the glove compartment so I just I
grabbed out and I grabbed like a whole
[ __ ] stack and I ran to the old dude
and um I think another couple of
bystanders all had to come out and tell
the dumpster to stop backing up because
he's just doing his job and you know
those things got Hydraulics and [ __ ]
yeah it's a [ __ ] loud ass car it's
crazy yeah
so you don't even know what the [ __ ] so
after you saved him did he teach you
Buddhist palm
no he started crying I was gonna start
laughing because it looks so funny so I
had to leave
crazy
what's crazy is growing up like every
time there was a mess in my car my dad
wasn't an Asian Dad so we never had any
napkins exactly so your dad doesn't
steal napkins dude I have tons of
napkins in my [ __ ] club no because he
laughed he cried like the he cried like
the viral video when you're being
serious you really were gonna laugh at
him yeah cause I was helping him and
he's bleeding right do your best
oh
I was like oh if I gotta leave I was
like I gotta he's like I can't I can't
[ __ ] be here for this [ __ ] maybe he
was doing his own ambulance sound so he
would get their attention yeah hit the
right octave because he's so old there
was no 9-1-1 they just had a [ __ ] that
gets the ambulance's attention oh [ __ ]
someone's hurt sounds like we're already
over there
let's not go there
you have to leave man well a trash truck
could hit this kid yeah it could be and
then it could have just went away and
then maybe at the same time another car
was speeding so someone thought it was a
hit and run but it wasn't him usually
for like mysterious situations like this
I tend to gravitate toward the most
simplest yeah usually I agree too I
think he fell yeah so my New York friend
he told me a story of uh one of his
friends or something like that where he
had one of those uh rentable scooters
and
hit like a pothole or something because
the New York sidewalks are like [ __ ]
up yeah and I went in a coma what the he
just hit it flew just comb up that's why
you gotta wear a helmet you know I've
done so much interest [ __ ] in this world
and I'm so lucky
nothing ever happened to me dude
a coma from that I saw a video of this
kid he was riding on one of those
[ __ ] runnable scooters
uh front wheel hit something went
forward right fell on the ground and
when you fell a [ __ ] truck came ran
him over and then he got up oh yeah what
yeah because he did the thing in mi3
where he's just like went flat stupid I
guess the wheels like didn't hit him and
he just went right under it right there
is correct he was like this and then
Philip Seymour Hoffman spoiler [ __ ]
taken out yeah and all that's left is a
shoe no but but like as far as like how
fragile our brains are I used to work in
uh in college I still work at like an
aquatic therapy place and um a lot of
people yeah you just help people that
have had traumatic uh it's like rehab
for yeah like people that can't walk
that well in person like so it's like
lesser gravity yeah so they're in the
pool and they're doing their exercises
[ __ ] like that uh one of my the guys I
used to work with he he was like a
chiropractor dude
he was in the bathroom one day just
fainted hit his head TBI could barely
walk couldn't do anything like his very
low brain function and it just like
something like that just falling like
that not even on a skateboard could just
change your whole [ __ ] life did you
did you be like you so weak full yeah no
I didn't say that oh that's crazy
I didn't say that I should have I should
have necked humor is the best medicine
they say it's scary how fragile we are
yeah because like you you slip in the
shower that's one of the that happens
like it's one of the leading causes of
deaths in America is like simple
accidents at the home like especially
the back of your head dude the back of
your head crazy that's why you gotta
have the [ __ ] little uh designs on
the bottom of the tub oh yeah that
Grandma had a little grip tape it looks
like flowers and [ __ ] Jill's [ __ ] mom
has one of those bathrobes that are so
goddamn old doesn't have the the rubber
bottom anymore so it slips one time I
came out and I [ __ ] stepped a little
bit too far and I [ __ ] slipped like
this
[Laughter]
like that like that's so scary bro it
happens and it happens it happens I
think it's scary if you're a tall guy
like you 40 000 people you got a longer
way down man a long way down it's like
Timber but I am for some reason like a
[ __ ] draft like I trip so often and I
never [ __ ] eat [ __ ] could you save
yourself I got a good little amount of
leg whatever the [ __ ] you got good
balance yeah well I don't think it's
that I just think my legs just just
catch myself from quickly but I have
[ __ ] balance actually oh really yeah dog
[ __ ] balance for sure
[Music]
[Music]